two coal mines are now the site of a
rescue operation and the Colombian
Central town of kukunuba
hoping their relatives survived the
overnight explosion
the noise almost knocked me out of bed
when other miners told me the mine had
exploded I was frightened because my
co-workers were working there
going down these mines which run more
than 900 meters underground Is A
Dangerous Mission authorities say
they've detected toxic gases like carbon
monoxide and methane in the shafts four
months earlier government officials
banned the mines from operating due to
safety concerns but they remained open
we're exploring different ways to use a
tunnel so we can safely reach the
missing Miners and have more than 150
people working Round the Clock
Colombia is Latin America's largest coal
producer accidents are common especially
in coal and gold mice underground
explosions killed about 100 people a
year on average between 2011 and 2022.
and now these families are hoping their
relatives won't become one of those
statistics
Al Jazeera